Hello Freak bitches.
The thing about the postmodernists,
and I'm going to speak mostly about
Jacques Derrida because I'll consider him
the central villain. Now. He actually, he,
he may make a point explain who he is.
Oh, he's a, he's a French philosopher,
French intellectual,
who became quite popular in the late
1970s and then was introduced to North
America through the Yale Department
of English. And of course,
English literature is one
of the disciplines that has
become entirely corrupt.
And so
Derrida wasn't Marxists to begin with,
but that fell out of favor because it
turned out that Marxist political doctrine
kept producing evil empires.
And even radical left French intellectuals
were forced to admit that by the mid
1970s, you know, they'd put their head
in the sand for 20 years, 50 years,
really, uh, thoroughly in the sand and
made sure their ears were full too.
But by the mid 1970s,
the evidence that that was the case
was so overwhelming that even a French
intellectual couldn't deny it anymore.
And so they started to play sleight
of hand with the Marxist ideas.
So instead of trying to
promote the revolution of the
working class against the,
against the capitalist class,
let's say they started to play
identity politics and said, well,
we can just separate everybody
into oppressed versus so presser,
but we don't have to do it on economic
grounds and so weak and we can call it
power instead of economics.
So that was part of it.
And then the other thing
about the fundamental critique
that Derrida focused on
this is this is this is really worth
laying out because the problem that he
discovered,
the postmodernist discovered
was discovered by a variety
of other people at the
same time in other disciplines.
So for example,
among the peep people who were studying
artificial intelligence since the early
1960s it was always supposed that we'd
be able to make machines that could move
around in a natural environment
without too much problem.
And the reason we could do that was
because the world in some sense was just
made out of simple objects.
There they are.
And all you have to do is look at them
and you see them. And that's vision.
And then the complex problem is
not how to see or what to see,
but how to act in
reference to what you see.
But it turned out that the AI
people ran into this problem,
essentially sometimes known as the
frame problem. And the frame problem is,
is that there's almost an infinite
number of ways to look at a finite set of
objects.
So the fact that that vision,
for example, it turns out to be way, way,
way more complicated than anybody ever,
ever estimated.
In fact,
you can't actually solve the vision
problem until you solve the embodiment
problem. So, uh,
an artificial intelligence that doesn't
have a body can't really see because
seeing is actually the mapping
of the world on to action.
And so that was figured out more or less
by a robotics engineer called Rodney
Brooks.
But,
but what's at the bottom of this is the
idea that any set of phenomena can be
seen a very large number of ways.
So like there's a bunch of pens
in front of me here, you know?
And when I look at the,
my brain basically notes that are
grippable object with which I can, right?
So I see the function like, like if
you look at a beanbag, you see a chair,
not because it's got four
legs and a seat in the back,
but because you can sit on it and,
and most of what we see in the world,
we actually see functionally rather than
see as an object and then interpret the
object and then figure out what to do.
So the function of the object constraints,
our interpretation, but there's an
endless number of interpretations.
So for example, if I was going
to paint that paint on canvas,
this set of pans and try to do
it in a photo realistic way,
I would be looking at tiny details of
these objects that the multiple shades of
red that are there and the multiple
shades of white and black. And you know,
I would decompose it
in many went many ways.
And so the AI guys ran into this problem,
which was that looking at the world
turned out to be exceptionally complex.
And that's still being solved
now. Okay. In in literature,
the same thing happened.
What,
what the postmodernist realized was
that if you took a complex book,
let's say the Bible for example,
or a Shakespeare play,
there's an endless number of potential
interpretations that you can derive from
it because it's so complex and so
sophisticated. So imagine that, well,
you can interpret the word,
you can interpret the phrase,
you can interpret the sentence,
you can interpret the paragraph,
you can interpret the,
the chapter, let's say.
You have to interpret that within the
confines of the entire work then of the
entire tradition.
And then within the context of discussion
that you're currently having and all
of those things affect how you're going
to interpret the play. So there's an,
so that their conclusion was,
well,
there's an infinite number
of ways to interpret a text.
And then their conclusion was,
well,
there's an infinite number of ways to
interpret the world. And there's a,
there's a way in which that's correct.
And so the next conclusion was,
there's no right way to do it
so you could do it any old way.
And then their next conclusion was,
oh,
and this is where the
Marxism creeped up again. Oh,
people interpret the world in a way that
facilitates their acquisition of power.
Now that's where the bloody theory
starts to get corrupt because yes,
a bit but also know, right? Because,
and this is why they're wrong.
This is why the wrong you see the world
is complicated beyond our ability to
comprehend. So there is a
very large number of ways you
can interpret it, but, but
you have to extract out from the world
a way a game from your interpretation
that you can actually play.
So if the lesson that you extract from
hamlet is you should kill your family and
yourself, then we might say that that's
not a very functional interpretation,
right? Because first of all, people
are going to object to that, right?
It ends your life. It ends many people's
lives. People are going to object to it.
And it isn't a game that you can play
over and over again in the world.
So when we're,
when we're interacting with the world,
you see what we're to do is to extract
out a set of tools that we can use to
function in the world because we're
constrained by the world so that we don't
suffer too much.
And so that the things that we need in
order to continue can be provided and we
need to extract those out in a way that
other people will so that other people
will cooperate and compete with us
in a peaceful and maintainable way.
So then you think,
well,
we have to extract out an interpretation
that allows us to live and thrive over
multiple periods of time in
multiple environments. Well,
we're doing the same thing
with other individuals who
are motivated the same way.
So there's a tremendous number of
constraints on our interpretations and the
postmodernists don't care about that at
all. All they do is say, well, no, no.
You can interpret the way the world,
the world anyway you want.
All people are ever doing is playing
power games based on their identity and
there's going to be no cross talk
between the power hierarchies.
It's not even allowed.
That's why they don't engage in dialogue
c just to talk to like let's say if
you're a,
if you're a postmodernist,
just to have a discussion with someone
like you, you know, a heterosexual,
what did they call it? A CIS gendered
male who have power, you know,
and and white to boot.
It's like that's,
that's an evil act in and of itself
because all you're doing by engaging in
dialogue with that person is
validating their, their power game.
That's all you see. And this isn't,
this isn't, this is no aberration,
that these people don't engage in
dialogue, that it's no aberration.
It's built right into
the philosophical system.
They regard the idea of the idea that
if you're in one power group and I'm in
another, the idea that we can step out
of that group, engage in a dialogue,
have our world's meat and produce some
sort of a understanding of it. Yeah. Yeah.
Some sort of negotiated understanding.
No, that's part of your,
your oppressive patriarchal
game. That idea, that whole
idea is part of your game.
So if I even engage in the dialogue,
I'm playing your game, you win.
It's a complete as complete.
People don't understand that postmodernism
is a complete assault on two things.
One is it's an assault on the
metaphysical substrate of our culture.
And I would say that the metaphysical
substrate looks something like a religious
substrate.
So it's a direct assault on that.
And the second thing it's an assault on
is everything that's been established
since the enlightenment, rationality,
empiricism, science, everything,
clarity of mind, dialogue, um,
the idea of the individual,
all of that is,
is not only you'd see,
it's not only that it's up
for grabs, that's not the
thing. It's to be destroyed.
That's the goal to be destroyed. Just
like the Communists wanted, you know, it,
the revolution to destroy the
capitalist system. It's the same thing.
These people now you might say,
well,
does every social justice warrior
activists no. This, it's like, well, no,
of course not.
It's not let any more than any,
every Muslim knows the entire Muslim
doctrine or Islamic doctrine or every
Christian knows the entire
Christian doctrine. You know,
it's fragmented among people.
But then when you bring them together,
the fragments unite and the
entire philosophy acts itself out.
So you don't think that this is in the
Pfarius plot by a few well planned out
individuals that have some sort of an eye,
an agenda,
that they're going to promote
this ideology because they,
and they understand what they're doing.
You,
you feel like it's what you're saying,
that there's a bunch
of different factions,
bunch a bunch of different parts to
this and it could be a lot of it is that
people feel disenfranchised
socially. Um, they,
they are empowered by their positions
in universities and by these insulated
environments and groups,
they're a intoxicated by the power that
they have over young people and shaping
their minds and, and, and,
and imposing their ideologies.
They receive feedback from these kids.
It builds up,
everything's strengthens.
They shore up the walls around
them and they push this forward.
And then when they have something like
this speech that you gave at mcmasters
and they get to actually act,
it unites them, unites them.
And this is what you're getting
from this glazed eye, you know cod?
Yeah, yeah. It's, it's as if it's
like Richard Dawkins id of meme.
You know, if you imagine that in
your, in your neuro neural structure,
whatever ideas that you're manifesting
are represented neuron by neuron.
Let's say it's a web of neurons,
not any one neuron has
the entire idea set.
This is obviously an oversimplification,
but you get the point.
There's a network from which
the idea emerges. Well the me,
my idea is is that an idea can rest
upon multiple individuals as if each
individual is a neuron.
And so,
I mean there are people who are more or
less fully informed as to the nature of
postmodern doctrine and they're
pushing it forward consciously and
unconsciously. There, there
are consciously pushing it
forward and acting it out.
And so there are individuals who are
more representative of the entire set of
ideas and individuals who
are less representative.
But if you get them together in a group,
the thing that animates them and
unites them is the common set of ideas.
And those ideas were produced by the
postmodern French intellectuals in the,
in the mid seventies, roughly speaking
shock, Derrida, Michel Foucault.
Foucault was the person who famously
pronounced that psychiatric diagnostic
categories were primarily social
in origin rather than biological.
And you know,
I read [inaudible] work,
I think it was madness and civilization
where he advanced that particular
doctrine. You can actually read Fuko
unlike Derrida and [inaudible]. Uh,
but I just found what he
was writing obvious. It's,
I knew from my clinical training that
psychiatric categories have a heavy
sociological construction.
Partly because psychiatry is into science.
Medicine isn't a science,
it's an applied science.
Those aren't the same thing at all. And
you know, a pure science is pure science.
It deals with scientific
categories like Adams,
but an applied science.
Well,
it's a compromise between all sorts of
different things and mental illnesses
themselves are shaped by
the social environment.
Even though often they
have a biological route,
the way they manifest themselves as
clearly shaped by society and language.
I didn't find his work the
least bit surprising. I thought,
well really,
I mean everyone who's a
sophisticated medical professional,
psychiatrists, psychologist,
everyone knows that it's like,
I mean there's a book called discovery
of the unconscious by a guy named Henri
[inaudible] that was written
in the believe in the
sixties great book on history
of psychoanalysis and like he covers the
shift in diagnostic categories across
time. It's self evident. So anyways,
there's all these French postmodernists,
they were all Marxists.
Most of them were student revolutionaries
in France in the late 1960s before
that all fell apart. And
they did two things. They,
they pulled out this a frame problem,
issue,
the issue of multiple
interpretations and said,
well there's nothing that's canonical.
There's no overarching narrative,
there's no real interpretation.
And I already said why that's wrong.
And then the other thing they said was
they did the sh this slight of hand.
So instead of the working class
against the bourgeoisie, it was,
it was race against race or,
or gender against gender.
Unbelievably divisive.
It's all they believe in his identity.
There's no individual man
that's gone with postmodernism.
This isn't an accident. All of
this stuff, it's not random.
It's driven by these ideas.
Like the ideas are always at war always,
and we're in a war between these ideas.
I mean Marxism,
we already know it was tremendously
powerful doctrine and this is its newest
manifestation.
What is the motivation behind the
individuals that are at the heart of this
movement?
Well,
I would say that the
motivations are as complex as,
as human motivations are in general,
but they seem to have solidified
into a movement. Right?
Well I think the dangerous part of
it is that the, it's, it's a kind of,
it's almost like a scape goat mentality.
It's,
it's almost like
psychoanalytic projection.
That's another way of thinking about it.
It's like one of the things that I've
come to learn and one of the things I talk
about a lot is that the, the battle
between good and evil, so to speak,
isn't between states. And it's
not between individuals precisely.
Although it manifests itself at those
levels. It's an internal battle,
a moral battle that happens inside people.
And so people have a broad capacity for
malevolence and for and for benevolence.
And that's a terrible war for people and
it's a terrible thing to understand and
realize.
In fact,
often when people realize their capacity
for malevolence if they're not prepared
for it, they developed post
traumatic stress disorder.
So that happens to soldiers in
battlefields. So they go out,
they're innocent guys,
you know, naive guys,
young guys and they go out onto a
battlefield and they get put in a really
stressful situation and you know,
they,
they step outside themselves and they
do something unbelievably vicious and
brutal and then they're broken.
They can't take that manifestation of
themself and put it with like Iowa Corn
Fed,
you know,
nice guy and no wonder because one is
like a flesh eating chimp chimpanzee on a
war rampage. And the other is, you know,
was a relatively well brought up and
polite farm boy from the middle of the
United States.
It's like how in the world you're going
to put those two things together. Well,
you can't, that's post traumatic
stress disorder. And to treat that,
my experience with post traumatic stress
disorder is that you have to teach
people a philosophy of evil,
of good and evil because otherwise they
can't recover. And I've had, I've had,
by the way,
in the last four months,
I've had two letters from people from
soldiers with PTSD and I met to personally
who said that watching my lectures had,
had brought them back
together because they,
they couldn't understand what
they had become before looking,
looking deeply at, at the,
at their malevolence now.
So I would say with regards to this
movement, this postmodern movement,
the malevolent aspect of it, there's
a, there's a couple of them. One,
it's complete,
unbelievably authoritarian.
Can I got a letter today from
a university student in Italy?
I don't know what university,
but she'd been having kind of a
flame war on Facebook with, uh,
with a social justice warrior.
And at the end she recommended that this
particular social justice warrior seek
out a local mental health counseling
unit and put a link to it in the,
in the exchange. And then she got
a letter from the university. I,
I guess the other person
that SJW type turned her in,
but she got a letter from the university
saying that that violated university
policy and constituted harassment and
that she should seriously consider
retracting it. And um, that,
you know, future employees,
employers might be looking
at what she posted.
And it was inappropriate to put that on
a public site. And it's like, I thought,
wow, if you, how could
you be so clueless as a,
as a administrator say to think that
your monitoring of your student's private
audiences,
you're monitoring it at an institutional
level and your intervention and threat
at an institutional level is
less dangerous than letting
to students, you know,
troll each other on, on a,
on a public social forum.
It's just, I just, I don't
know what to think about it.
It's just unbelievable that happened
and it's happening all over the place,
this sort of thing. And so there's
the authoritarian element to it,
which is a hatred of,
I think it's a hatred of
competence because competence
produces hierarchies that
aren't based on power.
I think it's a hatred of clear intellect,
um, hatred of clear interlink
Howso. What do you mean by that?
When you say clear intellectual,
you have a clear intellect
as far as I'm concerned.
I think that's why you're so popular is
because you pay attention and say what
you see and you're not too concerned
about doing anything other than that.
I mean, yeah, of course you have an
agenda because everyone has an agenda.
You can't help but have an
agenda if you're alive, but
you can temper the agenda.
Like you can be clued in enough to try
to listen and learn and watch and pay
attention to what your own senses are
telling you and try to articulate that and
that that's what the logos
is technically speaking.
And the reason I'm bringing this up is
because Jacques Derrida described Western
culture in a famous phrase.
He described it as fellow fell,
logo centric,
p h a l logo,
l o g o centric fell logo centric and
it needs to be brought down while the
Fallis part that's mail, the
logo part. That's logos. Now,
that's partly logic because the board
logic comes from the word logos,
but logos is a deep may,
much,
much older concept that
logic like logos is,
it's essentially,
it's a theological concept and
that's where things get complicated.
But you could describe it as uh,
as the manifestation of truth in speech
and the postmodernist they don't like
any of that.
So foul logo center, San Diego, San, it
would be the ultimate mansplaining. Yes,
exactly.
Yes.
Like any man who expresses a or tries
to correct a woman in any way becomes a
man's claiming to correct
anything in any way.
Particularly with you where the uh,
ted Cruz,
Sally Yates testimony that's
been going on in America.
Pretty fascinating. Cause
no, I'm not aware of that.
I saw an example of that in Australian,
our congressional debate where a guy was
accused of mansplaining by one of his
colleagues and really like tore a
strip off her quite nicely. Yeah.
So what's happening in the state,
you will,
Yates has just been pretty brilliant.
She was fired by the Trump administration
because she re rejected this idea of
what was the, uh, the very specific
thing was about restricting immigration,
about shutting down, uh, different, uh,
people that are trying to come
into the United States. And, um,
she had this debate with Ted
Cruz where she, you know,
just brilliantly shut him down with
her knowledge of the constitution and
knowledge of what is and what is not legal
or should or should not be allowed to
happen. And she was fired for it and
he was grilling her and his, you know,
he's a very smart guy, ted, although
I don't agree with him and I'm,
I agree more with her.
The wait was going down.
This debate was described as mansplaining
because it was a man talking to a
woman.
It's just a recent example.
I also read about something like that
with regards to the Supreme Court. Yeah.
Because somebody did an analysis showing
that the female Supreme Court justices
spoke less than the male supreme court
justices immediately attributed that to
sexism because you know,
how will pressed female
Supreme Court justices are so,
um, the, the, the, I still
want to get back to this,
that the hatred or the,
a dislike of clear thinking.
Yup.
Do you think that this comes from people,
I'm not even sure I completely
wrapped my head around this,
but do you think this is
from someone with, uh,
they understand that their logic is muddy.
They understand that they're imposing of
this muddy logic is illogical and some
sort of a way they feel it. They feel
it, feel it rather than think it,
I mean that,
that's the other thing is that there
isn't a lot of clear thinking on the side
of the social justice types because
a lot of what they're doing is real
emotional base level. Yeah. Yeah. Well,
they're the best personality predictor.
Okay.